hello how you doing
good how are you perry i'm good big
congratulations on the movie
i'm going to start with my most pressing
question first
are you as friendly as melanie is on
planes
yes i am
i'm incredibly impressed now just
because i'm curious
what is the most memorable random
interaction you've ever had on a plane
i talked to this older gentleman
um like a he was like a dad right um
on a plane ride from new york to los
angeles
about life and his daughter's going to
college and
uh education and health and ev for
six hours we landed in l.a
and i was like dude we talked the whole
trip and he was like thank you
and it was like this experience awesome
and then usually i sleep
but if i don't sleep we're talking and
we're talking the whole time
if you're down i can't tell if that's
super heartwarming
or also gives me six hour plane fight
anxiety
thank you so much don't get into a
conversation with me on a flight you may
want to shut it down
but i get people out i give people outs
i can't
that's that's important i feel like the
one time that i can't say no to it is if
the person seated next to me has a pet
then they're screwed oh you love pets
oh i love pets then you can sit next to
me all the time because i have my dogs
usually always
okay i'm glad we found a middle ground
here that that is that is my in the
conversation
i can find your anxiety right because
we're going to talk about dogs and
they're so
friendly and they're hypoallergenic so
you won't even better
exactly so i want to ask you about
working with evan and specifically what
she brings
to your performance as a scene partner
what does she bring out of you that
maybe you haven't experienced before
with a co-star
so that's a great question because i'm
always talking about like how much i
love her
and the real importance is what she does
to
like i've been trying to vocalize how
she allows me to be the best version of
myself
but it's been hard to do that so that
question is perfect
she makes me feel confident
comfortable powerful
she leaves she creates this brave space
where you just feel like you could do
anything
and that she's not gonna find you silly
or goofy
you know there's no judgment it's like
fly
and she's just flying next to you
and she really does empower you to be
the best version of yourself
which is a testament to how confident
she is
and understuff as an artist that she
doesn't want
she wants everybody to be great around
her and i
admire that so much because that is how
you make a good project we want
everybody to rise
and she is just such a like let's all
rise
and she's good to everybody and she's
kind and she's prepared
and so like she's not holding anybody up
she's not being nasty anybody she's
good to everyone so she's like
ideal yeah i'm not surprised to hear
that i feel like that radiates off
screen when you have something like that
and i can feel it in particular here
that's awesome so how about working with
miranda because
i have heard a lot about her very
collaborative nature but also the fact
that she comes to set with a vision
and then that vision can change so do
you remember a day
where maybe it was scary how much that
changed and how she kind of helped you
through
it i had a lot of trust in miranda from
the moment we met
um trust is built but i had
this belief in her because of her
the work that i had already seen of her
i trusted her as an
artist that i can give over and she was
going to make something awesome
i believed that i can that i was
i was lucky enough to be a puzzle piece
in like this beautiful puzzle she was
about to create and
she changed but so does everyone
and so does every director and you know
i don't think i ever was afraid
to be honest on the contrary i was like
i always find and somebody who directs
myself is that if they want one more
then give it to them because they didn't
get what they wanted and that's okay
you've given them a bunch of other cool
things like you know so
i always find it liberating when
somebody's like
i know what i want and it's okay that i
haven't found it yet and it's okay for
us to search for it
you know absolutely
is there anything you observed miranda
doing that you're going to bring to your
own
sets as a director maybe just have a
notebook on hand or something like
her notebook i talk about her notebook
all the time because then i just want to
get my hands on that notebook i was like
what's in that notebook
um you know her temperament
it's very calm and it's very loving and
i think that's imperative on set
and i was very inspired
and it was very aspirational
so that i may take that into mind that
you can always just stop
and be like give me a second to figure
out what i want
you know just like the music and so
that quiet command is beautiful
quiet command i just like that
descriptor
and i feel like i want to apply it to
everything i do
yeah just i also love hearing about
what a director does behind the monitor
to signal to their actor
that they like the take they're getting
so how do you know
that you are absolutely nailing
something based on
what miranda is doing behind the lens he
forgets to yell cut
you just keep watching and she does
and you'll you know so like the scene
would be done and you
still want to stay in there and you're
just like she's
living in this moment and that's when
you know you've done
a good job because she just will just
keep watching
oh i love hearing that so so much i
don't want to move on from this but i
really did want to ask you about
carmen san diego because
bringing back properties is exciting
gives us the opportunity to recapture
what people loved before but also adapt
them for modern audiences and you've
kind of already done that
with that property so what would you say
i guess are your
unique goals for the live action uh
feature instead dwayne who did the
animation um was
is brilliant is and i don't was is just
because we finished but
is brilliant is a brilliant man and did
such a phenomenal job at creating this
world because we know karma i mean i
grew up with carmen santiago
and it was mostly like the pbs game and
it was mostly like
the computer game but you didn't really
know anything about her
so dwayne created this entire and
incredibly
intertwined beautiful story with
backstory and all that
and so forth with the live action to try
you know ideally we would be able to
create
multiple films but to bring in this
first
film it is really imperative to us
to create this iconic character that we
loved
right that we didn't know much about and
give her a really
solid story that we all fall in love
with
so that's the unique challenge that
we are working on but i'm really excited
and hopeful because
it's coming together great
i've got high hopes i look forward to it
but first huge congratulations on this
seriously i just
adore this movie thank you perry thank
you so much that means the world to us
and thank you for supporting it